dopo il successo della scorsa puntata
nella quale tentavamo di replicare la
carbonara francese e dopo l'odio che
abbiamo scatenato su internet e di cui
in parte ci pentiamo fortemente
amaramente è arrivato il momento di
viaggiare ancora una volta all'estero e
di tentare una ricetta facilissima e
prettamente italiana che all'estero
riescono comunque a stuprare stiamo
parlando della pizza con l'anas
ciao ragazzi ben tornati ad una puntata
di cucina buttata è arrivato il momento
di allacciare nuovamente le cinture e
viaggiare oltreoceano per arrivare fino
in america dove fanno questa roba che la
pizza con l'ananas in multi la
conosciamo è presente in un sacco di
meme un sacco di persone la odiano e
fondamentalmente non piace a nessuno se
non a chi credo non abbia le papille
gustative che sono un sacco di persone
in realtà all'interno del mondo perché
perché la pizza collana se alla base
proprio della controversia legata alla
pizza cioè l'anas non si mette sulla
pizza ma siamo sicuri
l'abbiamo mai provata hai avuto forse il
momento di assaggiarla assolutamente sì
ho paura pure iniziamo quindi con gli
ingredienti che servono per fare la
pizza con l'ananas prima di partire col
procedimento volevo dire solamente una
cosa vi prego non generiamo odio siamo
qui per divertirci ho cercato di
prendere proprio la ricetta più schifosa
della pizza con anas ci sono alcune
curve mai solo proprio andato nelle case
degli americani dove proprio il forno è
un optional ok quindi
quindi sappiamo che la pizza con
l'ananas può piacere o non piacere
famoso una risata e continuiamo allora
per fare la pizza con l'ananas avremo
bisogno di ananas prettamente
all'interno di un barattolo di latta
cioè non è che devi prendere i miei
frutto e aprirlo capito raccoglierlo
accudirlo e poi spennarlo vivono e
tagliarlo a farlo nella notte nelle
cuamm e cade così dalle piante poi
abbiamo bisogno della mozzarella quella
lì dura quella lì che non butta fuori
nemmeno un pochino di latte quella che
fa questo rumore cosa schiaffeggiate
prosciutto una cipolla rossa
vi dico solo che era insieme ad altre
sorelle che hanno iniziato a buttare del
liquame quindi non so esattamente questa
cipolla che sapore abbia ma non credo
che se farà schifo sarà colpa sua e poi
abbiamo lui e molti usano la salsa
mourinhana qualcun altro se il ragù ma
abbiamo beccato alcune ricette di
persone che usano il ketchup ore prima
che arrivino qua sotto i commenti di pam
n dai che ha esagerato che sei ragazzi
ho visto una ragazzina mettere il
ketchup nelle penne lisce scott e senza
olio senza niente avete presente quelle
che mangi quando ti ho di ecco lei
aggiunge voleva molto sì lei lei non
aveva una grande stima di se stessa e
infine abbiamo lei
il cane è vero stanno abbaia li hanno
iniziato a bagnare i cani non parlo non
parlo base fresca per la pizza
sbam all'estero sono in pochi a fare
tutto quanto il procedimento di
lievitazione e compagnia bella hanno
queste specie di barattoli della
pringles che loro aprono e dentro ci
stanno che ne so la pasta per fare la
pizza la pasta per fare i biscotti la
pasta per qualsiasi cosa fanno questi
secondo me prendiamo una bella teglia
della carta da forno
[Applauso]
e sempre un colpo di tosse amici da mesi
scriviamo tutti quanti nel instagram di
enrico guarisci presto sotto la sua
ultima foto che moralmente sarà di 7
anni fa nel 2014 dovere appena uscito
dalla scuola
questa ricetta di pizza che non ci serve
la cucina ma basse temperature per farci
un bel cappio per impiccarci tac o da
mettere sulla nostra tomba iniziamo a
vagliare il nostro primo step è molto
simile a quello italiano però non so
perché fa fa fa particolarmente male
scusate non ho il mio grembiule
diciamo che mi sento più a mio agio
quindi che già deve esserci una bella
base e poi l'odore del caso a me fa
impazzire
l'idea che stia su una pizza mi fa
impazzire unesco il pivot scusami io so
che tu sperare di essere una margherita
ma non è stato il tuo giorno non tutti
vivono una vita felice carapezza non mi
sta venendo già l'acquolina io che
cucina questo grembiule stati ipsa
potremmo essere forse la cosa più
abominevole di questa giornata che
vedrete sul web
due video x me proprio il prosciutto
bravo l'è preso strong solo adesso mi
ricorda l'autore de il pan di spagna di
san valentino madre no no da vicino e
più buono ok ti fa solamente una
sorpresa all'inizio che piazzano il
prosciutto cotto che io di base non amo
particolarmente
ma credo che sarà l'ultimo proprio dei
problemi limiti forno no a un eccesso
secondo me si nasconde il ketchup
è come se non fosse mai esistito
tagliamo la mozzarella nostro ruggiero
per francesco che quello che ci presta
la cucina del cugino di cucina opera
cacciato da tutte le persone che
sentiranno capitoli presente l'odore del
ragù quando torni a casa dell'agenzia
che sta facendo i regolatori del
ciambelloni macchinista facciamo al
mentre la lady gaga e siccome lui non
stavo così guarda cantonate share
10 vecchi e adesso è arrivato il momento
l'occhio che ti guarda e io l'ho ceco
anas in di cuamm e stagno di ananas
mollicci e chiamate terribile ieri ho
chiesto a un ragazzo del supermercato
che ci lavorava dov'era questa roba è un
signore accanto ho fatto due parlare per
me non hanno detto che cosa volevo usare
se no ti picchiamo col bastone vi è un
esperimento li ha capito pensato che era
speriamo che il forno francia qualcosa
la brucia giusto per aggiungere quel
piccolo kit quelle calcio sulle gengive
la cipolla rossa non è comunque ha fatto
più male fare la carbonara ancora un
dato il maiale e loro la fanno bella
spicchio zza minimo dai poco a poco la
tassista fa problemi degli stadi tragico
quello che hai fatto
lo so che cosa peggiore non è per la
cipolla
se proprio le ha sentite buttate nel
forno alice migliori arrivo pizza con te
che è stato alla fine quasi 15 minuti
dai che tela dire fuori spinga
sciacquati un bell'aspetto guarda un po
cruda e cotta perché così moda 2 cruda e
cuba adesso ragazzi era l'elemento di
assaggiarla ma è molto calda
meglio così che però riconosce di
bruciare molto e non sento niente
la giustizia anche se vuoi 290 così
grande è sempre stato qui mentre scelte
la famiglia non è che chi quelle vuote
perché stiamo patate è un vero baffetto
invitante però c'è se tutti demonizzano
un fondo di verità ci sarà la mente
umana tende per preservarsi a voler
dimenticare gli shock e i traumi quindi
noi continuiamo a dimenticare quello che
ci hanno messo dentro
guarda che era del momento di
assaggiarla
ma che c'entra si limiterà ad assaggiare
non conosco però una fama e betta non
abbiamo pranzato in un centro luna il
calcio non è terribile
mancano senti murdoch perché la nana
seria che come io contavano riesco più a
saggiare con la roma bisogna associare
un pezzo senza non f
ford è un abominio da anche senza
dall'anas comunque ci sto curando rifare
la maglia fame perché non si accompagna
la scienza non sa stesso luca shop
questa pizza si commenta con un pessimo
qua avrete capito la non son certo
niente c'è adesso fan e quindi è
rimangiato pure il tizzone ardente di un
caminetto acceso da e non poco
quel fini comincerà a vomitare ok
ragazzi questo qui al mio tentativo
mamma mia
era quella roba che tu mangiavi pum pum
che vedo ogni a ogni morso dicevo siamo
arrivati alla fine di questo video
ragazzi fatemi sapere se avrete il
coraggio di provare questa ricetta in
questa vita in un altra
qualora aveste farlo fatemelo sapere
staccandomi su instagram facendomi
sapere anche se
commentate qua sotto con hashtag ultimo
respiro ma soprattutto fatemi sapere se
avete mai mangiato la pizza con l'ass
e se vi è piaciuta cioè esiste qualcuno
al quale piace la pizza con la non so
che ho sbagliato forse qualcosa io nel
procedimento
a me sembra di aver seguito tutto quanto
in maniera abbastanza corretta come
sempre l'invito a iscrivervi a questo
canale adattivi care adattivi care ad
attivare la campanella qua sotto per
poter essere aggiornati ogni volta che
c'è un nuovo video e soprattutto come
sempre vi dona viola appuntamento alla
prossima domenica con un altro video di
cucina ciao ma non si dice piaccia ha
detto tipo oddio cosiddetto e spero
faccia bene se ho detto qualche
strafalcione ragazzi e come vede
capitolini cominciano la mediana
annebbiato brutto